what is the most iconic moment in all of
one piece
now you yourself might or might not have
a very specific answer to this question
however whenever people ask me hey ohara
what's your favorite one piece moment of
all time
there are always a bunch of scenes and
events that immediately come to mind
but ultimately i can never decide which
one i really like best
there's just so much greatness to choose
from here
from very emotional stuff over brilliant
comedy
all the way to some of the most badass
moments in anime
and so i thought to myself if it's so
hard for you to pick your favorite
moments
why not revisit some of them find out
why they are great
and then pick a favorite at first i was
thinking about making this video a list
video
and simply presenting my top picks but
then i thought to myself
that a video the top 10 most iconic
one-piece moments
really doesn't fit in well with what
we're trying to do here on the channel
it also sounded like there were probably
already at least a thousand or so of
these out there
and so i quickly scratched that idea and
went back to the drawing board
and by drawing board i mean of course i
got a cup of coffee
and watched some anime because i'm a
goddamn genius when it comes to
procrastinating
but then i really sat down and this time
i fell asleep i honestly was a bit
discouraged whether i would be able to
pull this off somehow or not
and was ready to simply ditch the idea
and focus simply on my analysis videos
after all that's what i'm actually good
at and then it
hit me why not do exactly that
why not analyze these scenes and see
what makes them tick
why they become so popular and
ultimately pick the most iconic moment
in one piece
apart from a couple of fight analyses i
don't think i've ever come across a
proper scene analysis for an anime
and so i welcome you to my new format
the iconic scene analysis series
i think we might have to work on that
name though
i'm super excited to try something new
and i hope that this format is something
you will be enjoying as well
so let's give it a go to break down
every scene we will be looking at things
like
theme composition framing body language
dialogue symbolism music and voice
acting in the anime
the role the scene plays in the
overarching storyline
and much much more and so for the very
first video in the series
i thought it might be appropriate to
start with a banger right out of the
gate
with undoubtedly one of my favorite
moments in the story
and one of the best if not maybe the
best in zorro's arc
the nothing happened seen on thriller
bark
the scene takes place shortly after the
straw hat's united effort to defeat
moria and his giganteous zombie oars
and stretches from chapter 483 to
chapter 486
and in the anime it's episode 377 i
think
in case you want to follow along luffy
is knocked out from his intense final
battle
and the rest of the crew as well as
loler and to men
are resting after they finally got their
shadows back
however right when they have defeated
one of the shichibukai
kuma suddenly appears on the island he's
been tasked to inform moria of
blackbeard replacing crocodile
of ace having been captured and of the
potential conflict with the whitebeard
pirates
however upon reporting that moria has
been defeated by luffy kumar receives
new orders
to capture the crew and kill all
remaining witnesses
so no word of moria's defeat can leak
into the world
to ruin the reputation of the warlords
even more
kuma then complements the unconscious
luffy on the crew he has gathered
to which all of the straw hats react in
a hilariously flattered way
despite the serious situation they're in
and despite the damage all of them took
zoro immediately prepares to fight kuma
to protect his crew
and for the very first time in this
scene mentions his willingness to die
fighting if necessary
kuma however easily repels each of soros
attacks
and introduces his unique devil fruit
powers to the crew that allow him to
repel
anything as kuma catches zoro by
surprise
sanji jumps in for the very first time
as well to help zorro
however kuma takes no damage from either
of the two
and after proving his superiority he
offers everyone present a surprising
deal that goes against his orders
he will let everyone present on the
island live in exchange for luffy's life
but without so much as a second thought
all of the straw hats
as well as lolar and to mem refuse and
stand between kuma and luffy
as a result kuma takes out everyone
gathered there
with an enormous shockwave and
approaches luffy on his own
however before he reaches him zorro who
seems to be the last one standing
stands in his way once again this time
he actually manages to inflict some
damage to the warlord
only to find out that he's indeed a
cyborg developed by dr vegapunk
and kumar reveals the secret government
project of the pacifista
having witnessed kuma's true strength
zoro realizes that there is
no way he can actually win this fight in
his condition and he bows down to offer
kuma his life
instead of luffy's bargaining his
ambition to become the greatest
swordsman
before kuma can react however sanji who
seems to be on the brink of losing
consciousness
steps in prepared to in turn now give
his life
to save both zoros and luffy's dream
zorro has made up his mind though
and acknowledging sanzi's gesture he
knocks him out with his sword
kuma then proposes another trial for
zorro
using the powers of his devil fruit he
expels all of luffy's pain and fatigue
and gives a portion of it to zorro
telling him that taking in all of it
would kill him zorro however takes in
all of luffy's pain without so much as a
second thought
kuma then acknowledges luffy's crew and
leaves the island
and after regaining consciousness sanji
hurries to zara's side
finding him standing straight in a
puddle of blood
upon asking what in the world has
happened here
zorro simply states that nothing
happened
one of the most iconic lines in the
series
a bit later luffy is shown miraculously
back at full strength
while chopper states that the now
unconscious and treated zorro
only closely escaped death finally sanji
stops two of lola's men
sharing what has happened to not
diminish soros sacrifice
so next to the obviously fantastic plot
in here
what makes the scene so damn good how
did it become one of the most memorable
moments for zorro
well the first thing we should look at
is how this scene fits in with the
overall story
and what purpose it serves this epilogue
scene with kuma on thriller bark
to me seems to have four mage
implications for the plot of one piece
first of all it's of course meant to
introduce kuma as a character into the
story
while at the beginning of the scene oda
implies him to be a cold and unforgiving
government loyalists
hammered home by his epithet the tyrant
over the course of events
it becomes clear that kuma is in fact
sympathetic towards luffy and the crew
despite his orders and grim threats to
take luffy's head
he ends up letting everyone and thriller
bark walk away freely
his affiliation with the revolutionaries
is also
already hinted at here when he's
name-dropping dragon
and so in just a few chapters we get an
enormous amount of character development
for kuma that is still relevant until
now
when we're thinking about his role
during the reverie arc
secondly the entire scene contains
enormous foreshadowing for the next four
arcs
kuma is the first one to mention ace's
capture by the marines
and the upcoming conflict with
whitebeard foreshadowing both the events
at imple down
and marine fort at the same time the
introduction of his powers and his
combat superiority towards the crew
heavily foreshadows the events at
sabaodi and finally the time skip by
indicating that the crew
is not strong enough to face even all of
the shichibukai
let alone the marine admirals or the
yonko
thirdly by testing their resolve the
entire
sequence serves as the ultimate proof of
the straw hat's loyalty towards luffy
before heading into the crew's dark
trilogy arc of defeat
these three things aren't as obvious
when reading or watching the scene
itself
but do a wonderful job as an underlying
message and vibe here
that really pays off in the story going
forward
however the last and undoubtedly most
impactful purpose of this moment
is the strong characterization it gives
to sanji and especially to zorro
establishing both of them as luffy's
left and right hand
and lifting zorro up to be to luffy what
really was to roger
more than a crew member more than a
friend and
even more than a first mate but a
brother standing side by side with luffy
and being a pillar for his captain to
lean and rely on
it is some of the best characterization
in the entire story
and even more than before zorro's
sacrifice
made him one of the most respected and
most beloved characters of the series
so now let's dive a little bit more into
the details here
and i'll be referencing both the anime
and the manga here
both of which i think have done a
fantastic job with this scene
and both of which have their innate bits
that they excel at here
what i think really stands out in the
scene in particular
even for animated manga is the
character's body language
and the fantastic dialogue here kuma's
appearance
switches between laid back and natural
such as sitting on the wall with his
legs crossed reading his book and
talking to the tendent mushi
and at other times moving and behaving
mechanically and stiff
the same goes for his lines that
alternate between robotic
very simple sentences and words on the
one hand
and quite eloquent and intelligent lines
on the other that hint at a smart and
compassionate person
oda wonderfully uses every aspect of
kuma to hint at the dichotomy of his
character
as an intelligent and friendly member of
the revolutionaries
and the brainless and unforgiving
machine following the world government's
orders
by switching between human and machine
the straw hats meanwhile
express nothing but unity loyalty and
determination through their body
language and their dialogue in the scene
all of them see the danger they're in
and yet all of them make it clear
through their words and general demena
that they will stand by luffy no matter
what
especially zorro and sanji leave
absolutely no doubt
that they see each other as luffy's
representation to protect the crew
and uphold his determined and unwavering
will in his death
in more than just one scene zoro's face
and the heavy breathing included into
his lines
hammer home the feeling that he's
already way beyond his last reserves of
energy
and is mostly running on willpower and
determination alone
nonetheless the look in his face when
stepping into the bubble of pain
suggests nothing else than zorro being
fully prepared
to die here without any regrets
it's a very powerful visual depiction of
emotion and motivation
that the manga does an especially
amazing job with
and i can't even begin to describe how
powerful zoro's pose at the end is
covered in blood and at the brink of
death the anime meanwhile does
a wonderful job in terms of sound design
and music in the scene
the build up to the climax is
accompanied by uneasy orchestral music
giving the scene a threatening cinematic
and epic feel
and once sanji regains consciousness and
hurries to find zorro
there is no music at all implying
something terrible has happened
only to hear the epic theme of the very
strongest starting to play
and seeing zoro's defined face absolute
goosebump material here
there is also a nice amount of symbolism
in the scene the most
striking however is without any doubt
kuma removing
all of luffy's pain and fatigue and
shaping it into an enormous red bubble
making it visible to us and to zorro
what luffy endures every arc for his
crew's sake
at the same time zorro literally
embracing luffy's pain and taking it in
is a wonderful symbol for the
relationship he has with his captain
beautifully executed here the last thing
i want to look at
is the framing in the scene all
throughout the sequence
kuma constantly towers over everyone
else
representing his superiority and the
helplessness of the crew
he is literally an obstacle too big to
overcome
and this consistency in his framing is
only broken
one soro offers his life to kuma in
luffy's stats
which then shows both of them at the
same level
through his words zorro has literally
earned to look eye to eye with kuma
and has passed his test for the crew
some other great compositional scenes
include sanji standing between zoro and
kuma and zorro
bowing down before kuma to back for
luffy's life all of which create an even
more emotional and impactful atmosphere
than this moment already carries
and ultimately zorro bleeding with his
arms crossed
is shown from below his waist after his
sacrifice
oda has lifted him to higher moral
grounds and giving him the perspective
that kuma had throughout the scene so
while each of the elements here
plot dialogue composition etc is
beautifully crafted by oda
it's the sum of these elements that
together create a moment that surpasses
its individual parts
it creates one of the most emotional
inspirational and suspenseful moments of
the series
and is a prime example of what makes one
piece so great
if you made it to this point please let
me know your thoughts on the new format
and if you would like me to keep it
going thanks guys
peace